[موسيقى]
يلمع ويغمز
يقف في مجد مبنى المتحف المصري الكبير
مناسب حقًا للفراعنة هذا هو
المبنى الرئيسي للمتحف قابل الدكتور
الطيب عباس لدينا
المجموعة الكاملة للملك توت عنخ آمون
لدينا أكثر من 60 6000 قطعة أثرية  والتي
سيتم عرضها لأول مرة في
مكان واحد إنها ضخمة إنها
ضخمة حقًا هنا هذه هي مسلة الملك
رامزي الثاني لقد كانت رموزًا كانت
رموزًا كانت هناك تمامًا مثل
علامة عند مدخل
المدن المهمة وقلب كليهما
بعضًا  ربما يمزحون أنهم بنوا الأهرامات بشكل
أسرع قبل 2000 عام، وقد
استغرق المتحف عقودًا من الزمن في التصميم والبناء،
ولكن الآن الجوهرة هنا وقد تم
بناؤها بشكل رائع، هذا هو المدخل الرئيسي
المؤدي إلى الردهة التي تعد مركزًا
للمتحف، فلماذا  إنه مهم جدًا،
هذا هو الملك رامزي الثاني،
حسنًا، الشخص الذي بنى الكثير من
الانهيارات، الشخص الذي بنى الكثير من
القلاع، هذه هي النافذة التي
تقولها، لذا تم إنشاء هذه النافذة فقط للسماح
للضوء بالتواجد على وجه  الملك
غراماسي الثاني في يوم ولادته
وأيضًا في يوم تتويجه، هل جربته لكننا جربناه
بعد، نعم
يعمل، نعم يعمل، نعم أعتقد أن
المدخل مذهل، نعم،
أقصد الطريقة التي بها  لقد فعلت ذلك،
الطبيب الجيد يسمح لي فقط
بمعاينة سريعة للمتحف الذي يجب أن يكون مفتوحًا
بحلول نهاية العام، وينبغي أن يكون ذلك
بينما تتحرك الأشياء الكبيرة إلى مكانها،
أشياء الأساطير خلف أبواب مغلقة،
لذلك هذا هو
توت عنخ آمون، نعم هذا هو  توت عنخ آمون
وهذه هي المجوهرات التي تم
العثور عليها على جسد الملك، لذا
كان بعضها في الواقع بالداخل
والخارج وتم العثور على بعضها في
صناديق فاخرة مدفونة داخل أوه، انظر إلى
هذا يا إلهي، يبدو الآن سؤالًا غبيًا
لأنه 3  عمرها 000 سنة نعم ولكنها
كانت موجودة منذ أكثر من ثلاثة آلاف
سنة وكانت في صندوق في صندوق في قبر
بدون ضوء أو بدون ولاعة كم هي
هشة
هذه الأشياء القديمة ولكنها
هشة حقًا وهشة للغاية ولكن
الأشياء في حد ذاتها مذهلة للغاية،
نعم أشعر
بالتوتر بمجرد مشاهدة هذا الفريق في
العمل، أعني أننا سمعنا جميعًا عن بوق
وكارمن وهؤلاء السيدات يقومون بإصلاح
أغراضه التي يبلغ عمرها أكثر من 3000 عام، ماذا
يحدث إذا تغلبت عن طريق الصدفة
الأرضية كيف وجدتها بأي حال من الأحوال،
لا ينبغي عليك أن تأخذهم من هنا
إلى هنا ومعرفة أنني لو كنت أنا لكانوا في كل
مكان
[موسيقى]
أجنبية